make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I want to talk you're getting
into the newest one of the newest story
about Superman what I want to do here is
I want to talk about the crime syndicate
for a second right because the way the
stories straight you know transpired so
far is that Jonathan Ken's kind of just
been like thrown into these crazy
circumstances where he was literally
thrust until like Earth three right
which is basically a universe where that
where everything is backwards right like
everything is everything that's normally
good in the main DC universe is evil
right so instead of the Justice League
of America you have the crime syndicate
of America and and while the character
roles do change in terms of like owl man
versus you know that instead of Batman
and things like that a super woman which
is played by Lois Lane instead of like
you know Supergirl by you know with with
Kara zor-el the way this kind of plays
out is this it's I guess really Wonder
Woman you know with Diana Prince the way
this plays out is kind of intriguing and
I want to sort of offer some explanation
here so when it comes to the crime
syndicate and what a lot of you guys
probably saw in terms of the reviews
regarding been Miz's whole you know the
set of events there's a lot of people
are saying it doesn't make any sense the
crime syndicate shouldn't be here and
here's the reason why so in in the new
52 when DC rebooted back in 2011 there
was this kind of ongoing set of events
that were happening behind the scenes
sort of under the current that we would
get these little snapshots of that led
into darkside Ward and so this really
kind of came to a head with regards to
the crime syndicate during the events of
forever evil and the way this happened
was - the crime syndicate essentially
like invaded the main DC Universe it
really wasn't until you started getting
further into the story and none of the
meat potatoes of everything - what you
discovered was that the anti-monitor had
shown up on earth in earth 3 and was
basically like wreaking havoc and really
kind of like obliterated everything and
suddenly crime syndicate flying you know
fleeing for their lives and they invaded
the name DC Universe which is why
forever evil happened now at the end of
that story when the crime syndicate was
ultimately defeated for the most part
like like it kind of led into different
story arcs right so like the rain double
long to power ring who's basically
played by who's kind of like a cowardly
version of Hal Jordan basically pass
itself off - Jessica Cruz could became
like the new Green Lantern right which
is the one that you see right now in DC
comics but the idea was that with
regards to characters like superwoman
with Ultraman with with like ala man
there were kind of holdovers right like
there was like the event and they were
just kind of left in prison and we
didn't really know what was gonna happen
with him by various circumstances they
were basically eliminated but like dr.
Manhattan killed Alma and different
things like that but but essentially DC
Universe rebirth number one tied up all
the loose ends the crime syndicate was
by
all centers of measurement gone like
they were effectively eliminated and so
this is them kind of like returning it's
basically been to saying like the crime
syndicates back on earth three the issue
with this is that there's no explanation
of how they got there you know as far as
we're aware there's not been any kind of
a reboot rightly so like the universe
was recreated there's no indication that
happened instead what it seems to be is
been this kind of telling a story saying
I want to use a crime syndicate so now
they're here you know the reality is
that while I really kind of think like
most people are jumping the gun right
like most people are just kinda like
this has been discrete Bendis you know
and that kind of a thing the truth is
that we don't really know because
Doomsday Clock has an ended and we don't
know what kind of effect that's gonna
have on the DC universe as it would that
being the case like it could be one of
these things where business is really
kind of like essentially spoiling the
ending of Doomsday Clock bit like the
way dooms like clock is gonna end like
dr. Manhattan's gonna go back and undo
what he did and that means that like
darkside war never happened and like an
T auditor never invaded earth three and
there's like all these things that could
come out of that or it could be that the
naysayers are actually right that it's
basically been is just kind of ignoring
all continuity for the purpose of just
wanting to do or three we don't know but
the dr. mains this is the first time
Jonathan Kent's actually facing off
against the crime syndicate and that's
an important thing and the reason why is
because where everybody goes to attack
him it's actually Ultraman who takes
them and then whisks him away and where
John's that Kent looks at him of course
because Ultraman is an alternate
universe counterpart to Superman he
looks exactly like his father and it
takes a minute or two for like Jonathan
to realize this is not my dad and
Ultraman really begins to kind of kind
of talk to him directly now Ultraman
really seems to kind of take a special
interest in John and basically say like
there's nobody coming for you there's
nobody going to save you it's really
kind of a twisted set of circumstances
the terms of him kind of manipulating
John and then like tearing him down and
where John tries to escape tries to get
away one of the things he realizes is
that there's no Sun you know there's no
Yellow Sun in this universe like it's
just kind of dim so it's a strange
scenario because the indication seems to
be that like if there is no Sun there
will then one how in the world is earth
exist and to like how does all this kind
of come together it's really been is
sort of playing with things so the
reason why is because earth three was
never fully explored by DC it's really
been is just kind of doing what he wants
here because he can but the overall gist
of this is that Jonathan Kent is
essentially like his powers are kind of
going away and the reason why is because
it's not really been this pulling
anything out of his backside is because
this is how Superman works right like
Superman is a battery so it's like
taking a car battery and sitting it on
concrete you leave
there long enough and it's gonna drain
and so it's basically the same thing
with Superman right you take Superman or
any of the any of the Kryptonians who
are powered by a Yellow Sun and you
remove them from a Yellow Sun as time
progresses they'll begin to lose their
powers because that solar energy and
their cells will start to deplete but
when John is kind of recalling this
story to his father and his father says
well how long were you there
John just doesn't really give an answer
because the indication is that he
doesn't seem to know where at least if
he does he's not spilling the beans
right now instead he's just he's been
there for a long time and what Ultraman
does is bring him things like pigs
basically the ability to kind of like
feed himself but that's really it he's
like literally stuck in the middle of a
volcano out in the middle of nowhere
and so it's kind of interesting because
Ultraman then shows up here and
basically says hey look I kind of help
me up and think about this for the last
few days and I kind of have a question
your father as you know him is a guy
that you love and you trust any kin you
care about he's everything to you but I
wear this face and I'm stuck in what
amounts to a universe that really is in
a lot of ways akin to hell and if that's
the case then maybe you're here to be
tested maybe you're here to be tested
your particular to test your potential
that was the whole idea behind you going
out into space with your grandfather
anyway was to test your abilities and it
happened to be that like you ended up
here in our three separated from jor-el
as well that's the case then maybe
you're here for the purpose of testing
me and that's what we really kind of get
to get this interesting development with
with Ultraman because what Jonathan says
is all he would do is talk about himself
he would show up and talk about himself
all the time he would cry different
things like that and that's not
something that we usually see from
Ultraman most most depictions of
Ultraman as a character in DC Comics is
that he's just an evil version of
Superman he would just show up and he
would do some really really crappy
things and then it maybe it takes you
know earth to serve an earth want
Superman teaming up to defeat him maybe
it's just the main DC Universe Superman
defeating him on his own whatever the
case is we've only ever really seen him
as like a violent and vindictive person
we know the earth that like the crime
syndicate is screwed up right like super
super woman is banging ala man and like
it's it's kind of crazy but like she was
married to super or to the Ultraman so
it's kind of a weird finicky scenario
but like basically what Jonathan says is
that as time progressed what he began to
realize is that whenever Ultraman showed
up and sort of like complaining and
crying about his life that he would in
turn like take off and then he would
vanish for some measure of time as the
way that Bend is kind of depicts
Ultraman here is that like the hardcore
evil vert perception of himself that
basically we've
scene is a sham that the guys basically
a coward on the inside they're like
instead of confronting his problems
head-on he just cries about them well he
just whines about how bad things are and
then never does anything to fix it which
is kind of interesting to basically
portray him as essentially a coward
right like here because it's kind of a
cowardly thing like man the world's been
really mean to me and I'm just gonna sit
here and cry instead of like bucking up
and trying to do something to fix it you
know like it really is kind of like an
indication of cowardice and it's kind of
cool to see that that kind of flipped on
the character of Ultraman do be somebody
disagree with it but I actually like
that development of him I think that's
one of the cool things that kind of goes
into it but Jonathan uses this chance
and basically says like this is my way
to get out of here it's my chance to
escape and so using what little energy
he has left basically makes his escape
out of there and then takes off to like
one of the cities that he can he can use
to find the location of the crime scene
it can at least their main base of
operations and as he goes through there
he begins to learn what earth trees like
they're basically it's a place of
suffering right like it's one of these
things where it's like the only people
who deserve to survive or the ones who
can survive if you can't make it on your
own that's your problem you know there's
no Lindy there's no there's no helping
hand there's no one there to like make
things easier for you that is literally
a screwed up and terrible place where
people struggle day in and day out
that's basically what it is
that where they would normally look to
superheroes to protect them instead they
you know the superheroes are there to
like basically serve out their own ends
you know it's it's a terrible place to
live in now that aspect of Earth 3 we've
known for a long time are like that's
not new that's not a Brian Michael
Bendis thing we always knew that like
Earth you know the I guess a planet
Earth and the earth 3 universe it was
basically like a twisted evil version of
the main DC Universe but it's also kind
of cool to see it as this sort of little
bit of an expansion here odd to see this
kind of kind of you know a little more a
little bit of a I guess the light
shining on this small little segment of
this universe again never really
understood why DC never would never seem
to explore it I think it'd make for an
amazing series you know I think it'd
make for more than a few volumes you
know again write it like injustice gods
among us and then make it in continuity
but what Superboy went when Jonathan
shows up to the to the main base of
operations for the crime syndicate
trying to find a way out he encounters
superwoman who of course again is Lois
Lane in earth 3 and so this basically
kind of leaves off with him you know
presumably gonna have to face off
against his mom which is kind of cool at
least a three version of his mom but
it's kind of interesting because like
the experience job that the job's going
through is as much one about like mental
torment as it is about like hey you're
becoming a much
stronger version of yourself but one of
the things I hope you guys are also
noticing here is that it's actually kind
of screwing John up it's kind of messing
him up in terms of his perception of the
world and everything that goes along
with it but with that being said guys
we're gonna go and bring this video to
an end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you